in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jamie
is with us hey Jamie how are you I'm
going awesome Dave how are you better
than I deserve sir where are you from I
am from hazard Kentucky hazard Kentucky
now where's hazard as it is in
southeastern Kentucky South Eastern okay
in the mountains yeah it is in the
mountains that's where I work I'm
actually from West Virginia Clarksburg
West Virginia oh yeah I've worked there
firms is that where the Dukes of Hazzard
is that where the name came from that is
except they had to spell it with two Z's
I believe because it was some kind of
like lawsuit or something I'll go get
mad yeah pretty cool man that's neat
Wolfe good to have you so you're here to
do your debt free scream yes I am very
neat and how much have you paid off
thirty three thousand dollars how long
did that take you exactly two years
excellent making what kind of money
27,000 Wow
you've lived on nothing or did you sell
something no I actually threw about
11,500 at the debt and then everything
else about twenty two of it was was cash
flowed so don't be in rush yes I have
and my mom knows that righteous in vain
you get care packages from home yes I
worry about you eating enough yes I do
oh she's listening so she's probably
laughing right now because that is the
truth that's fun man you did you killed
it all no income you paid a ton of debt
that's right hey first TV contract I'm a
sports anchor and reporter at wYMT TV
still don't get that much money when you
sign that first first contract so my
contracts have been may hopefully I get
a bigger contract River I go yeah and
you keep getting better and you get
bigger markets and so on yeah it's a
yeah because entry-level in broadcast is
starvation you know and radio is the
same too but you're doing great man
congratulations that's awesome so what
set you on this course two years ago
tell me about your journey well I
started in May of 2013 at wYMT and we
have a woman who does like hair and
stylist and we go to Knoxville to do
that when you first start and so in
August of 2013 I met her and I was
talking about heard about my student
loans because that's what all my debt is
I had no credit cards or anything like
that and she told me you should listen
to Dave Ramsey you should check this guy
out so driving through Knox what I
actually heard you on the radio and that
was when you had I think one hour of the
of the show on iTunes
and I would just download that 30-minute
40-minute segment every single night and
I would listen to it and then you came
out and we you have all three hours and
I would downloaded the app and and I
listened I've not missed a show from
November 2013 to November 2015 I wasn't
the only single yeah every single show
in the audio archives longer that's cool
and it worked
yeah I also read the Total Money
Makeover like as soon as I really
started listening I went to the Hazzard
or the Perry County Library and and and
took out the total money bait makeover I
read that thing in like a week
yeah but and so you got on the budget
what was the hardest thing you did to
get out of debt ah you've done nothing
you had no life um I just it's just
disappointing I mean I couldn't go buy
new shoes you know I couldn't do a lot
of things I just the stuff that you
would want to that a normal 25 year old
would want to do you know travel you
know goat goes somewhere you know of
course I don't have a lot of time and he
was because my job takes a lot of my
time better but I mean just little
things like that
honestly that how does it feel now you
must feel like you've lost 100 200
pounds it feels awesome because I'm not
throwing seven eight hundred dollars you
know three fourths of my paycheck at a
student loan now thankfully I have low
rent too I only paid 375 for rent so I
got to thank my landlords for that
because I landed in a in a great place
you can't
hey buddy Chris Hogan here at age 25 to
now be debt-free do you understand what
your future can look like I do don't you
get excited about that
I get jacked up I get really jacked up
because like I said I know that I don't
I know I'll make more money eventually
hopefully and I yeah I'm so excited
that's what gets me pumped and just
fired up to go out here and now and and
leave a legacy it's I tell my mom that
all the time now thanks to you Chris and
Dave it's just it's not about I think it
is about building wealth but it's also
about leaving that legacy to your to
your children or to your mom or to
whoever you know I think that's what
it's all about and that got me so fired
up from day one that's what it was about
for me very cool that is cool you gave
yourself the ultimate gift for Christmas
this year my friend yes that you gave
yourself
freedom great job thank you so much Oh
congratulations man that's very very fun
you did very well okay do people make
fun of you uh you know every yes ever
every time I would mention your name
people didn't really get excited about
that weather does that work there's like
three or four people maybe that even
knew you and then I would tell them what
you know what I was doing and stuff then
you know it wasn't necessarily making
fun of it you just get to look at it and
they didn't care you know you're crazy
yeah yeah hey so what do you tell people
the secret to getting out of it is
you've got to get you've got to find
something that they get you fired up I
mean you have to have something to get
you fired up and you have to have a goal
and you have to set those goals and you
have to go after them that's exactly how
I got my job because if not I would have
probably never would have got a job like
you know a TV job looking so young and
all that I mean you just have to be
passionate about everything you do in
life if you want to accomplish anything
like that if whether that's getting out
of debt getting a job or or whatever it
is being a good basketball player yeah
so your your mom must be really proud
she is Dave I'm an only child I lost I
lost my father when I was in eighth
grade to cancer and so you know just
it's a big deal it's a big deal you're
hitting it out of the park man
congratulations very cool
I'm very proud of you sir thank you
you've done good work absolutely amazing
all right Jamie from Hazzard County or
hazard Kentucky and $33,000 paid off he
threw 11 at it and then he rolled up his
sleeves and lived on nothing he did it
in two years making 27 thousand a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream I'm gonna count out because I'm
only going up from here one two three Oh
and the lobby goes wild as well they
should as well they should that's cool
stuff
well done Jamie well done excellent
you're right Chris that the future so
bright you need shades yes that old song
is true right there it's this is there's
so many places he'll be able to go
because it's in it you know his incomes
gonna collapse aleut Lee and then and he
knows how to handle money now and so
he'll be able to manage it as it goes up
rather than manage it as it goes down
that's all some people do well and Dave
for the people out there listening I
want them to set some real goals for
themselves going into this next year if
you're sitting down and you're spending
time right now checks to try to attack
attack that debt let's make 2016 the
year that you send them final checks I
want you to buckle and give yourself the
gift by next Christmas of being able to
keep more of your money and giving
yourself a raise get out of debt get it
out of your life and you know it is a
good time of year to sit down you become
it we're not quite that close enough to
Christmas yet but you know about the
time you get close to Christmas and and
right after sometimes the week between
Christmas and New Year's people do more
introspective thinking and future
thinking and vision thinking than they
do even after the first of the year it's
almost like a reset time in our lives
it's a really good time to get you know
what you talk about to dream again it
really is I think the more Dave we dream
and we start to realize that I'm chasing
something they'll have that desire
that's gonna motivate us that's gonna
help us understand what we're
sacrificing and why we're willing to do
some things different and just like
Jamie out there taken back his legacy
the opportunity to build something I
want more and more people feeling
inspired to be able to do that and
that's why the dream part is the very
first part of the riq and so if you
don't know your number and you haven't
done that yet go to my website chris
hogan 360 plug in your dream then plug
in your numbers love it do it do it do
it chris hogan 360 dot-com and that's
where the are IQ is a retire inspired
quotient and everyone needs to know what
your number is yes if you don't know
what your number is how can you hit it
too many people run around with their
retirement planning and everything else
in their life and say ready fire aim
ready fire aim it's ready
a fire not ready aim aim aim ready aim
fire squeeze the trigger Chris Hogan
thanks for being with me thank you for
having my friend you can follow him at
chris hogan 360 on twitter on facebook
and that's his website too chris hogan
360 calm for the riq
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others